[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and skincare nerd
today we're going to be talking about
skincare when it comes to wearing masks
I had a lot of requests about this topic
as well as how to look after your hands
when you're washing your hands a lot
which I talked about in my last video
and again I went to lots of
dermatologists and asked them for their
advice on dealing with skin issues when
you're wearing a mask skin problems can
come up when you wear any sort of
covering on your face this can happen
with cloth masks which you might wear
when you're going to the store this is
one that my aren't sewed for me or it
can happen with surgical masks which a
lot of health care workers wear on a
more extreme level it can happen with
hard respirators like this one which I
wore during the bush fires last year in
Australia a lot of health care workers
who work closely with Kovac patients
will be wearing these for hours on end
so here's a guide to the common skin
issues that might happen when you're
wearing a mask and how to deal with them
if you'd like the sort of video give it
a thumbs up subscribe to my channel and
click the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos first off let's talk
about the sorts of skin issues that you
might see when you're wearing a mask for
a long period of time with a looser mask
the main issue is going to be skin
irritation this includes dryness itching
and redness this is called irritant
contact dermatitis and this happens
because of the extra heat for the mask
the fact that your breath and your sweat
are making a very moist and humid under
the mask plus there's the friction of
the mask rubbing against your skin you
can also get a free from the material
rubbing against your skin and physically
blocking your pores this is called acne
meccanica respirators are a lot harder
and they fit much more tightly against
your skin this means you can end up with
hives and pressure sores raw skin and
blisters different components of the
mask like adhesives rubber straps and
even free formaldehyde from n95
respirators these can all cause irritant
and allergic reactions this means red
and inflamed skin itching and rashes so
here's some advice for what to do when
you're wearing the mask
[Music]
firstly it's a good idea to avoid heavy
makeup and foundation under the mask
thanks for pressure and friction from
the mask can mean that you get spots and
acne even if you don't normally react to
these products you can also use a
moisturizer or a berry cream like zinc
oxide or dimethicone base 3m Cavill on
under the mask especially on the spots
where the mask rubs and causes pressure
this is generally on your nose the size
of your face and under your chin be
careful if you're a health care worker
using a respirator if you're using these
products right before you put on the
mask it can affect the quality of the
seal so check if this applies to you you
can also use protective dressings like
hydrocolloid bandages and skin shapes on
areas where the mask rubs or if you have
a wound dr. Angela martyr recommends
removing pressure every 1 to 2 hours
where possible here are some tricks from
dr. papri for relieving pressure from
behind your ears you can use a paper
clip or a strap to turn the loops that
go behind your ears into a strap that
goes around your whole head
if you have longer hair you can also
wear Princess Leia buns and put the
loops around those make sure you monitor
your skin for signs of infection and
seek medical help
[Music]
here are some products that might be
useful in a skincare routine if your
skin's been irritated by masks it's a
good idea to use a mild soap free facial
cleanser or makeup remover wipes right
after you've taken off the mask dr.
Anjali mato recommends using lukewarm
water to wash your face not water that's
too hot or too cold because that can
cause irritation
you should also pat your face dry with a
towel rather than rubbing if you do
develop acne some good anti acne
ingredients are benzoyl peroxide
salicylic acid as a lake acid sulfur and
retinoids if your skin is easily
irritated by benzoyl peroxide dr. papay
recommends washing it off after 20 to 30
minutes which is called short contact
this can help reduce irritation and
dryness exfoliant some retinoids work
really well if you have acne but they do
cause a lot of irritation so if your
skin's already irritated it's probably
best to avoid these or use gentler
versions in terms of moisturizers dr.
Adeline recommends moisturizers which
contains glycerin ceramides hyaluronic
acid and niacin amide these all very
gentle on your skin and good for helping
barrier repair you can also use thick
emollients like Vaseline and a KO fall
to help your skin heal you can also try
using dimethicone based barrier creams
or products like la roche-posay sea cap
airborne b5 if you have a rash a few
dermatologists also recommended trying
some over-the-counter 1% hydrocortisone
cream you can use a thin layer twice a
day for a week or two and this will
reduce itching redness and inflammation
you can also talk to a doctor who can
prescribe a stronger steroid cream
another problem that can develop after a
while is post inflammatory
hyperpigmentation these are patches of
brown pigment that develop after your
skin's healed if you want more tips on
how to fade this you can check out my
video on hyperpigmentation if your skin
is very irritated then it's a good idea
to get rid of irritating products from
your routine until you stop wearing
masks so much so things like exfoliants
and retinoids
the people I spoke to also gave me some
extra tips for wearing masks remember
that the front of your mask gets
contaminated after you've worn it so
don't touch it
dr. perry recommends that if you're
planning to reuse a mask you can store
it in a Tupperware container put a
Tupperware container over your mask take
off the straps and then you can store
the masks in the Tupperware container
when you reapply it put the Tupperware
container on your face and put the
stress back on it's also a good idea to
wash your hands before you put on a mask
and after you take it off I hope you
found this video useful if you did you
can give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
my channel leave me a comment if you
have any more tips on using masks thank
you to all of the experts who shared
their tips with me I've put their social
media accounts here so give them a
fuller if you want to find out more
about the science behind beauty products
you can follow me on Instagram and check
out my blog see you next time for more
science-based Beauty content
you